okay hi everyone welcome back to another
livestream if you don't know me my name
is Gwen and I run a YouTube channel
called Faraday Academy or I do mostly VJ
s and Jango content if you're interested
in that the link is in the description
below so today I'm gonna be building the
last free code camp project or the last
fronted one of the series again in VJ s
and it's the Pomodoro clock so yeah you
can find this on free code camps website
so I do want to show you so about five
years ago I think yeah around five years
ago when I was looking for my first
developer job
I built this clock you can see the
background image is broken now but it
basically had a timer and I could change
the time and I could take a break if I
wanted to start oh good it's that and
pause and etc so I thought that was kind
of cool I can find all my old projects
and rebuild them now five years later
okay so let me close that of course this
is kind of spaceship II looking you know
it doesn't look great so hi Aneesh hi
text that's good to see you again so I'm
going to close that in my repo so this
is also linked in the description below
so you can see free code camp projects
view in my github and I let me so in the
Pomodoro clock folder I have a readme
with some of the requirements of a
Pomodoro clock basically a timer a
special time of the special name and
this is the mock-up that I have so
Pomodoro short break long break and then
I'm thinking about having a settings
file or settings menu and pop-up so yeah
users can change the amount of time for
each thing like the amount of time for
the actual Pomodoro clock or the short
break of the long break and I have all
of those in the requirements here all
right so I'm gonna go ahead and get
started so this time actually let me
zoom in actually yeah so this time I'm
using a purse for UJS vcli to bootstrap
the project and then I'm going to be
using beautify for the UI components
InDesign I used bootstrap a couple times
in Cline once but I just really like to
beautify I think it it'll give us a nice
design it's way more than we need for
this project but yeah we can just use
what we need out of the library so let
me go to my terminal some in free code
camp projects view and I'm gonna CD into
the Pomodoro clock folder and now in
this folder I've read me in mock-ups I'm
gonna create my app in this folder so
I'll use view create and then app name
we'll just call it Pomodoro or Pomodoro
app actually because I think that's the
standard that I've been using for the
rest of the apps
okay so I'm gonna actually manually
select features this time so I don't
need a router or view X again CSS yeah
so that's the one I want I want to use
sass so do that you just like with our
prevention only yeah normally I do
prettier or something but for the stream
I just like fewer issues with I guess
non error linting went on save is fine
dedicated config files alright so while
that's building hi Sasi how are you so
that should take a minute to build and
then I'll go ahead and pull up the
beautify documentation so I can't
remember if it's beautified j/s alright
here's the documentation
and basically yeah they recommend a CLI
install as a CLI plugin so it'll set up
everything it needs to set up for me and
then I believe oh no it's going to
create all this for me so I think I
won't have to import anything else on my
own
I'll just do view ad beautify and I'm
still waiting for the project to build
all right it's almost done [ __ ]
generators that's a good sign
additional dependencies I'm good I'm
happy to be able to stream on free code
camp today
let's see CD Pomodoro okay good so it's
built and now let me go into my app
beautifies similar material UI in react
yeah beautify is a material design
framework material you I haven't used
that for a while but I think I mean the
look of it was definitely gonna be but I
don't know how similar all the
components are and stuff what they offer
versus what beautify offers okay so I'm
in my app let me open this in a code
editor and now I will run the
development server
and I should be able to open it
localhost:8080 cool and I have my view
Jay s boiler plate oh yeah before I do
anything here because I want beautified
to set itself up for me
so before I change files on my own I'm
gonna do oh wait not a BM I'm gonna do
view ad beautify to add that CLI plug-in
there are uncommitted changes yes I know
about those
all right so it's asking me to choose a
preset and I'm just gonna do the
recommended one
so this will add all the setup and
config for me yeah so let me run the
server again
it does take a while for this to build
all right
so anyway insource here in app-v if i
added all the beautify components here
and then they set up my app oh wait it's
in here
yeah they set up the v-app wrapper and
then yeah be content for me to put my
main content in and then they gave me
this app bar then i'm not actually going
to use for this because i'm going to use
some tabs so i'm going to go ahead and
get rid of that hmm all right so that
got rid of it and now the rest of the
beautify components here I'm gonna go
ahead and get rid of those as well and
those are in hello world so let me just
delete the hello world component delete
that and I'm gonna create a new file
which will be I guess I'll just call it
Pomodoro dot view and in here then put
the template
just a div for right now and now let me
import that component into here instead
of hello world so Pomodoro
and Pomodoro okay components Pomodoro
okay so now this component is registered
and now my page only says clock all
right so now I need to look at my
mock-up so I'm gonna be doing most of
the styling first at least getting these
tabs and then some kind of box in the
middle for the timer and getting it all
this to display and then I'm gonna start
making the actual timer function so
first I'm gonna get some tabs I think so
let me go to beautify and search for
tabs okay bTOB's component this is fine
if I go down I can see some more
examples like this one where everything
is contained in one box and I believe
this is inside a card because that's
pretty similar to what I want
yeah it's inside a card and then they
have the v card title I don't know if
I'll have a title but I definitely want
tabs so let me go into Pomodoro now I'll
just delete this row let me add a V card
and then the tabs
all right and so I need a V model for
the current tab background color color
grow hmm I wonder what grow is oh I
think it's where it stretches the whole
width of the container maybe I can try
it so let me first the model the tabs
and I'm gonna say I guess I'll say timer
type because my tabs are all if the
Pomodoro long break or short break so
I'll have to create those here in a
script tag I'll create the data method
so oh wait
didn't need that all right I'm gonna do
timer type and this will be I guess I'll
do one because the I think the tabs will
default to a number like 0 1 2 unless I
denote that it's a string so let me
actually do 0 okay and now let me put
some actual tabs in here so it's V tab
and that will give me the title at the
top and then I could loop through tabs
or yeah I think I'll loop through the
tabs so let me do I guess tab titles as
an array I'm gonna call this Pomodoro
and the next one short break
and the next one long break
and I'll just do a V tab here and then a
v4 directive inside and so I'll do title
I guess tab in tab titles and then I
need a key here so key and that will be
just tab because those are all unique
names so oops I can close that and then
close the tab and then inside the tab of
course I want to display the title let
me zoom in one okay and then I want to
display the title so I'll say tab so let
me see how this looks and alright so I
see I think this is just the card don't
think it's showing anything
okay there's a vCard there's V tabs
inside and the item group okay so I have
V tab let me see what I'm missing here
from the dock so okay they're just
looping through the tabs there and I
wonder because I have the light theme
but it doesn't seem to have anything
inside of it anyway but I could change
this to dark I think there and that
didn't do anything so let me undo I'll
have to look up themes later but let me
see why the tabs aren't displaying so
let me open this up
okay so in the item group tab slider
yeah so the tabs aren't displaying at
all so I'm showing tab in tab titles
yeah everything should be working let me
take this card and put it more in the
center of the page or further down so I
can see better so class equals I'm gonna
give it a margin top of eight okay
so that bring the cut brought the card
down and now I'm gonna give it a width
so I think I can say let's see promise
circular okay I don't know if it has
classes for width so I'm just gonna add
some styling here so I can style the
card a little bit so I'm gonna say style
and let me go ahead and use sass here so
I'll do laying equals sass and then I'll
do what is it it's probably a V the
class is probably called V card - oh I
did okay thanks I'll go and fix that tab
tab titles oh I did okay thanks
okay so here I'm gonna do oh now it's
failed to compile oh it doesn't like the
dot anyway I can just real quick yeah
the the class is v card so when I
reference the v card class and do a
width Missa a width of I don't know 400
pixels
okay not not wide enough let me just set
it for 600 then all right that looks
okay and now I want it centered on the
page so I could do a grid system which
would probably belong in the app
component so I could do here like the
container and then close that and then
the row okay oops and then inside I'll
do a V column and then small of six
columns and offset small of three
columns okay so let me put the quotes
around that - I think I need quotes all
right
okay that's pretty good
and all right now I need the actual card
content inside so let's see okay get out
of that component now I have V tabs here
and then after so outside of e-tabs I'll
put oh no it has to be inside of the
tabs so let me see what component I use
for that okay it's V tabs items B tabs
items and then that's also V modeled to
the current tab so let me do the tabs
items the model and this will be I guess
timer type
okay and then inside of e-tabs items i
would think it's v yeah v tab item
inside and then okay they're looping
through and they're also doing a card
inside i guess to give it some spacing
and then they're giving it the prop flat
so i think i'm gonna do the same thing
so let me copy this alright
and
okay now I have to fix these tab items
so right now I'm just gonna work off a
one tab so I'm going to completely get
rid of the loop color basil I don't
think so
oh there's nothing inside of the card so
what should I put in here I'll put I
guess just a placeholder for now so zero
zero zero zero okay cool
a timer and now so also inside but
that's not giving me any spacing for
some reason I thought it was gonna give
me spacing but that's okay I can add a
padding class here then so class equals
padding all of five let's see yeah
that's better
and now let me add buttons here so the
it's a V BTN or V button I can't
remember
all right button
there's one thing I love about the
beautified Docs is that they have so
many playgrounds so you can test out the
buttons in the browser here but I just
want basic button
yeah it's V BTN so I'll do TN and then I
need three buttons to start and then B
BTN stop and then reset and the start
button will be I guess I can is it color
or variant so I can do primary for the
start button okay cool and actually
these look kind of weird next to each
other I wonder it I know there's a
button group somewhere here so let me
see what the button group looks like oh
this looks like they've updated this I
haven't looked at it in a long time okay
multiple toolbars let me see how it
looks with a button group where's their
basic example
so the BTN toggle actually I don't want
toggle maybe I'll just leave separate
buttons yeah oops didn't mean to get out
of there yeah I'll just leave separate
buttons for now let's see
and these let me make the timer bigger
so I can use some of their font classes
and oh did I call it Oh type in their
typography section text in typography
okay tear out the sign so okay these are
their defaults anyway but I think
there's a list of classes for bigger or
smaller I guess maybe I guess maybe that
was some other framework I'm thinking
yeah alright so I guess what I'll do
here is just add a class of time and
then here I'll do time and style that
class by the way I'm using sass if you
haven't seen indented syntax before it's
not the default syntax but it's just the
one that I usually prefer I think it's a
bit easier to read and write and you
also get some other shortcuts that I
don't believe are in the regular syntax
for sass but you can do basically the
same things so for time I'm going to set
a font size and let me just look first
at what this font size is so in the h1
I'm computed I can see font size is 32
pixels right now so let me do let me try
80 pixels make it really big okay I
think that's good it should be a big
timer now the font weight is
I wonder if that's just the default
I think it's using robot oh yeah it's
using robot oh I don't know what I have
available to me but I can try setting
the font weight so it's not so thick and
dudes like a 400 okay cool I like that
better
all right so that's good I can also do
text-align:center yeah I like that and
now I guess I should start doing the
actual timer and then I can fix other
things as they go along so for the timer
I'm gonna use of course JavaScript set
interval actually this is kind of
bothering me real quick so let me go
back to tabs just for one second and use
that prop to stretch them I think I
think it's this grow prop that will
stretch them all the way across the page
the third tab looks bigger yeah because
it there's this blank space on the edge
there so let me okay so in here I'll use
grow yeah and now it's it's completely
stretched out all the way across it
looks much better
and with this centered and then the
buttons I'll figure out what to do with
them at some point and then add icons to
the buttons to actually let me go ahead
and do that since I'm RT doing the
styling here so with the buttons
actually the stop button I'm gonna give
it a color of error
yeah okay I have these and actually I'm
gonna go ahead and get the icons for the
buttons because I can do that in a
minute
and where is it okay so when beautify
when I added it as a vcli plugin i think
that it set this up for me but I can
check
so in the plugins v2 fine and no it
didn't
okay so I want material design it's
already doing everything else for me so
I think I'll just add the icons object
here icons and then icon font which
should be MDI I think I think that's
what it usually use so icon font and
then MDI and yeah let me see if now so
let me go in the start and try to add an
icon there
hmm where is it yeah V icon and then I
can pass in the name of the icon that I
want so the icon and then I'll do em di
- whatever the name of the icon is so
let me see if there's a start icon just
takes a minute to load or no I want a
play button so maybe it will be play
yeah I kind of like the circle one play
circle outline so let me do em di - play
- circle - outline okay cool and now I
have the icon in the button now it
doesn't look great because I think I
have to give it a left prop yeah so it
pulls it away from the text and then let
me try to make it small - and see if
that looks better
yeah I think that fits in with the
button size that I have so now let me do
the same thing for that rest of the
buttons so for stop and let's see oh
yeah I'll copy that
and then I have to figure out it would
be nice if there was just stop circle
outline oh there is nice and then reset
what would reset be called what was the
first thing I typed in start yeah I
think restart that's a good one so let
me do restart
let me start yeah and see oh wait I
accidentally changed the stop one so
okay now and now I can change the reset
button so let me start okay cool I think
there is actually a refresh one but okay
reload give a reload one restart looks
good I really like how that looks for
some reason maybe I'm just seeing
something new okay so let me Center
these buttons and give them a little bit
of spacing so I can put I guess I can
put a wrapper around the buttons and I
could give it a class of button group
okay then close the div
and now actually so these buttons are
the button groups inside of the card so
I can also do display flex and then a
line items Center is it a line or is it
justify no no it's justify justify
content maybe it's not oh oh yeah that
makes sense
it's because well as I said oh yeah it's
because I'm doing flex here and I have
to I have the button group and then I
have this and then I have the h1 yeah so
you're right flex Direction column flex
column yeah and then here which I mean I
already had this though so but now I
think I can do justify cons content
center or let me just look up flex there
flex classes real quick okay so they
have justify
okay it's just justify justify:center
and I thought because now I'm doing it
as a column it would be justify Center
it let me see now I think it's a line
items Center let's see flex a line a
line items they have a line Center okay
cool that's good now I'm gonna give
these like a margin of just a few pixels
in between the buttons and see so I'll
just add them as classes here so let's
do we're actually
oh I don't have it here but I'll just
add it down here
the BTN and then add it as margin let's
see
margin left margin right is there a
margin why I can't remember I'll just do
margin and then do 0 for top and bottom
and then 2 pixels for left and right
yeah I think that's pretty good
it separates the buttons a little bit
all right
I'm happy with this and now yeah there's
probably the best-looking of all the
projects that I've made so far so I
almost want to take a second just look
look at it I think it looks pretty nice
so now yeah let me set up the timer so
in here
I'm gonna need some methods methods an
object and I'm gonna need start and then
a pause yeah I'm just gonna use stop for
pause because there's really no
difference thanks I don't think I don't
see any difference between stop and
pause because this is just stopping the
timer and resetting is what actually
actually resets the timer so I'll start
now means stop and reset
okay so I think on my old Pomodoro I did
have pause but I had no stop so I think
it was just like renaming of it
start stop reset
okay so I'm going to start with this
start one which I need a set interval
and pass it a function and then I need
the interval to run every one second
so wait 1000 milliseconds and then so
every second I'm gonna have to
recalculate the minutes and seconds here
so I'm gonna 1 I'll need these on data
so need minutes and let's see this yeah
cuz I'll need to make these strings at
some point because I need leading zeros
on them let me make them a string and
see
ok so let me do this then let me do
total seconds which will be a number so
it starts off with the default is well
know I based off of the timer type okay
so let me just lay these out so I need a
display minutes and a display seconds
right and those will both be strings and
then I need some kind of actual total
time that I can recalculate every second
and then change or update the display
times so let me do should I call it
total I think inside of these minutes
and seconds I should put them inside of
a display object anyway so let me put
these inside and then so inside of
display and then let me say total
seconds and actually this I could do
that as a computed property no no
because I'm gonna reset the number of
total seconds if they change to like
Pomodoro short break long break
okay so I'll have total seconds and the
default again will be 25 so 25 minutes I
have to put that in seconds so 60
seconds okay so I think I think that's
good right
and then let me put the display actually
up here now so let me see
so this will be displayed dot minutes
and then this display dot seconds okay
and it's still displaying the same thing
because I have those as strings down
here now the total seconds let me look
at the total seconds oh I did get view
dev tools in brave so just in case I'm
having to look at this a lot I'll open
the brave browser so you can see it
better okay so in Pomodoro yeah total
seconds is 1500 okay so now I want to
start actually so now I need to
initialize figure out how I'm going to
initialize these the seconds here so I
could actually do these as computed
properties computed
and then based off of the total seconds
the display minutes and display seconds
updates so I think that's what I should
do right but then yeah then I would I
guess I would call them I would get rid
of them in data and then just call Oh
display minutes and display seconds and
computed and then based off of the total
seconds so let's see four minutes I
would just return total oh yeah and then
I have to check if it needs a leading
zero okay so but first let me do total
seconds times 60 then I have to wait no
no yeah no no it's divided by 60 it's
like that's gonna be a really big number
of minutes
so total seconds divided by but divided
by 60 and then floor it so math dot
floor and then this one will be display
so this one I'll have to do the
remainder just like trim the seconds off
the end so I'll do
okay so total yeah total seconds divided
or I think I can just do the modulus
right and get the remainder of seconds
that should work and now I have to check
so here I'm gonna do con seconds equals
total seconds actually not constant so
be let seconds it's total seconds
modulus 60 and now I need to check if
that's a string so if no I mean if it's
less than 10 so if it's a single digit I
need to append only oh give me an error
so I need to append a leading zero if
it's a single digit or the clocks gonna
look really weird
so if seconds is less than 10
I kind of don't want to change between
strings and numbers here so if seconds
is less than ten I guess I could return
a leading zero plus seconds that would
turn it into a string otherwise I would
just return seconds
Oh am I missing something Oh total
seconds is not defined oh it's this
total seconds yeah this dot total
seconds and this dot total seconds okay
so I'm gonna actually need this same
logic inside of display minutes so I
could do another method here to call
like if seconds is greater than ten so I
can do format's time let's see okay so
let me do format time and move this out
of here I guess so be yeah let me move
all this logic into here minutes could
probably not need that the leading 0 the
thing is if I don't have a leading 0
here then it's gonna change like this
whole timer would shift to the left so
it's going to move around the page I
want everything to stay in the same
place so the same number of digits I
guess ok so I'm just gonna pass in time
as a number so time return a string if
time is less than 10 return 0 plus time
so now I can call format time Oh else I
need to return something so return
I'm not to string just to make it always
return a string so now I can do I can
always call the format time function and
then do the same thing here or I can do
Const minutes equals that and then
return format time minutes okay this
will be constant and now I need to put
these in the shouldn't it be less than
oh yeah I thought that was less than for
something yeah thank you
Oh Tom that's why I was wondering why
you had that I thought maybe I was
forgetting an HTML tag you're right
thanks everyone it's less than okay so
now let me put these in the Dom display
minutes and display seconds
Oh format time oh it's this dot format
time where is it where is it
yeah here have to call the method okay
so this dot for that time cool sweet so
now I just need to start the timer all
right so I have the set interval here so
first let me make a method on the start
button so I'll do at click equals start
and I'll go ahead and add all these act
clicks so for stop it's at click equals
stop for reset it's at click equals
reset all right
okay so I am starting a set interval
here and so in set interval every second
I'm gonna have to recalculate the total
seconds so I'm basically gonna just -
one second off of total seconds
I guess so total seconds - equals one
and oh it's this not total seconds this
dot total seconds let me see how that is
sweet cool all right but there's no way
of stopping it now so I'm gonna let that
keep counting down so to stop it I need
to actually have a reference to this
interval so that I can clear it what if
the time is at zero I haven't gotten
there yet the time it's probably gonna
count down to negative numbers right now
but it's not there yet so thank you
let's see so I have to split oh I don't
need this display anymore because I have
those in computed now I do need so I
need a reference to this timer I'm kind
of waiting to see what happens if the
minutes are correct when it counts down
yay cool so now I need a reference to
the timer instance that I start so I
guess I'm just gonna call it timer
instance and say yeah I'll start it with
null I guess so I have a timer instance
and I'll set this dot interval so this
dot timer instance so now I have a
reference to the timer instance as long
as I don't start multiple instances
because then I'll just have no reference
to them so what I can do here is use
this dot clear interval oh and then pass
it no no it's not this what am i doing
it's a this dot time or instant so I can
clear interval on the timer instance and
then for reset I'll go ahead and do this
so I can call this that stop which will
clear the interval in case it hasn't
already been cleared and then I can
reset the time so for right now I'll
just do because I'm I'm not dealing with
the breaks yet so I guess I'll just do
this total seconds is 25 times 60 so
total seconds is 25 times 60 when I
reset it
okay yeah and that's one reason why I
wanted to use beautify today because I
knew it'd be a little bit easier to make
a nice-looking app versus just trying
out kind of different design frameworks
each time alright start stop okay start
goes down again stop stop stop
oh because I click start twice okay
we're gonna have to fix this book reset
I'm gonna have to refresh so if I only
click it once and then stop you know I'm
doing a clear interval on it so I can do
start/stop reset okay that all works but
if I do start and then start again and
then start again see how fast it's
counting down cute clicking start and
then I stop and because I lost
references to all of those intervals
that I started all right let me clear
that so I'm gonna have to do some kind
of check here so before I start I should
actually reset should be disabled when
it's running that's a good idea
so here let me just do this real quick
so let me do this dot stop before it
started so now I can't
so if I click start multiple times here
it doesn't matter if I click stop it
still works
okay so reset disabling reset it's a
feature
yeah I don't have to work as long as my
timer goes faster
okay so reset how do I so how do I know
because let's say I clear interval here
let me actually see what it is after I
clear the interval because I don't think
it's a is it a fault does it is it a
faulty value let me see
okay so inside Pomodoro what is interval
right now okay let me refresh it because
the timer instant should be null
starting out
yeah timer instance is null right now so
let me start stop yeah it's still
pointing to the same timer instance even
after I stop or refresh so what I could
do is in reset I could clear that
instance so that no no no no that won't
work nevermind that was faulty logic
okay what should i do then so I could
set a boolean maybe I'll set a boolean
like timer going or something and that
way I can know so I can disable the
reset button
like if timer started unless someone
else has a better idea that's what I'm
gonna do so is is running is running
is that a good idea so it starts off as
false and then in in start I'll do this
dot is no because so reset if I want
them to only be able to reset if it's
already stopped then I need to know if
it's currently running yeah so I think
I'll just automatically in the start
function I'll do is running is true and
in stop I'll do this dot is running is
false oh and then let me get go to the
button now in reset I'll do disabled
here so I'll put disabled equals is
running so if it's running it will be
disabled let me see if that works
yeah it should I guess it should be
disabled here or if it matters so now
when I start now that it's running it's
disabled when I stop it it works again
okay cool
what's next let's see
I wanted to add a progress bar oh and I
need to do the brakes let me do the
brakes first how how is that gonna work
[Music]
so for short break and long break
actually I only want to change the time
here I want all of these features still
here so I wonder if I could do so really
all I want is one tab so I wonder if
there are events let me look at tabs
again here there must be an event I can
capture and just change the time let's
see so okay yeah I'm in tabs now then
the API I can see events okay so there's
a change event emitted when the tab has
changed and this is in the fee tabs
component so I can capture that here I
think I can so let me do at change
equals
making sure I can see everything all
right what was I just doing oh yeah so
add change equals um what should I call
this so change change tab change timer
type timer type and then I can make a
method for that so I'll do it here
and I should so I should get the number
of the tab I think so let me just log
out that number and see if that changed
cuz I don't know if I'm gonna be
intercepting their event so yeah let me
see okay
let me open the console oh wait
Jim change timer type is not defined on
the instance but reference during
rendering I think this is an old error
the content is deprecated oh right right
use V main instead why I set it up from
there there CLI so that's weird I
remember so they changed this this is
something that vide if I changed so I'm
but I might as well update it so it only
takes a second okay
so it wants me to use of the main
wrapper instead of the content so let me
see if that went away if it still works
yeah okay so now when I change tabs
yeah it's showing me the table numbers
wait long break to that one okay yeah
so now I see the tab so I need to change
the time based off of the tabs so I
should have the time stored somewhere
and
[Music]
so I have tab titles here and I wonder
if I should do objects because I need
the number of time for each one of these
so I think what I'm going to change this
to is so here I'm gonna do current timer
I'm gonna break everything so to current
timer and then here I'm gonna do timers
and I'm gonna change these into objects
oh yeah name and wait let me fix fix all
this
alright so current timers which is
actually this so this needs to be each
one needs to be its own object so the
name and then I'll put time or I'll put
minutes minutes will be 25 for this
timer cuz we'll just assume they don't
want to time seconds for right now
okay and now I'll put minutes for a
short break will be five minutes and
then oops for a long break it will be
[Music]
minutes
I don't know so some people do 25 some
people do 10 but hopefully I'll get
around to doing a settings menu in this
stream so they can change the time for
it oh yeah there we go
so timers is a whole array of objects
now current timer is the index of where
the timer is in the array so I'm gonna
have to change okay so here's the
v-model so change this to current timer
and then timers so where are my tab
titles oh they'll be in here so timers
what did I call that I can't remember
what I called it already yeah it's just
timers so for timer in timers and I'll
set the key as timer dot name and then
this will be the same thing so timer dot
name and does it work wait I have timer
type is not defined on the instance but
reference during render
oh yeah v-model timer type so this
should also be current timer
and then I'll just update the method
name to match so current timer and then
change this will be current timer okay
so now this should all work and this
actually you know you know I might not
even want this inside because all these
tabs are as inside of the card here and
I don't even need this inside of a tab
item I could just not have any tab items
since I want this to stay in perpetuity
I don't want it to move or change when
the tabs change I just want the number
to change so I'm capturing the event of
the tab change but I don't actually want
all of this inside so I think I can just
get rid of all these tab items here and
see if that works
oh no didn't really like it
okay nevermind apparently it does not
work
so I guess I need tab items so how do I
make this stay then I mean what if I
what if I just take the card out and if
I take this v card outside of tabs oh
because I left it inside so let me see
what happens if I take it outside oh
yeah that works perfectly so maybe it
was just because I had that inside of
tabs let me try to get rid of these then
I think I just made a mistake yeah whose
because I accidentally kept this stuff
inside of the V tabs okay so I didn't
need that that's good can we refactor
the tab yeah we could
do we need to even this whole component
is only 111 lines long if we were to
take out some of the logic the tabs
really only takes up like this is all
the tabs is all the V tabs
it's these like eight lines of code so
it's not that much we could probably
eventually move I guess some of this
stuff out
or maybe just move everything out into
components let me get rid of this color
basil because I don't know why it's
there okay so now like 30 minutes left
okay so timer works shows up so I'm
getting the event so what do I want to
do with this event I want to change the
type so what I'll have to do is change
the current oh cool yeah so well that
should be easy because I can change the
current timer yeah five times at the end
I will refactor current timer equals I
guess there's none because that will be
zero one or two
and then okay so if the current timer is
zero one or two I need to calculate I
need to recalculate total seconds so
when the tab changes I'm gonna have to
call reset
yeah I'm gonna have to call reset here
and pass in the total seconds I guess no
okay so I'm setting the current timer
let's say that I called a method change
current timer
I changed the current timer now I have
to recalculate the seconds so I should
be calling a reset this dot reset
because I do want I want to stop the
timer and I also want to reset it but I
need to be passing in yeah let me I need
to be passing in the minutes so yeah
because I'll be able to get the minutes
off of here and then calculate so I'm
gonna pass in the minutes and then this
is gonna be minutes minutes times 60
so here I'll have to pass in the this
dot timer's the num the index of which
timer
I want of the current timer this dot
timers dot minutes yeah and then I'll
get the minutes of the current timer so
dot minutes pass the timer object do I
need the object for anything else other
than minutes because I'm also gonna be
calling this reset from here so yeah I'm
gonna be calling reset from here so I
need to do I need to also pass in the
minutes here so I wonder I guess I just
do the same thing only it will be this I
don't need that this dot
so I'll pass in the minutes there too
when I click reset ok sweet let me see
if this works
yeah it works I can stop I can reset no
I can't
okay so reset doesn't work but the reset
here does work let me make sure there
are no errors yeah so this works but for
some reason when I started stop it reset
that doesn't work anymore so I have some
kind of a bug here a timers is undefined
oh oh right
numb so I obviously can't do this so I
need to do current timer because there's
no numb there so now I can go into
timers pass in the current timer which
is the index of the timer and do dot
minutes so I should be able to do that
let's see stop
reset okay sweet I am happy about this
reset
okay so there are a couple things so the
timer let's see what we were talking
about earlier
oh yeah the timer will count down to
negative numbers so we should stop it
and hmm so I should set kind of a
catch-all in here so if this dot total
you should change the interval to 10
milliseconds Oh to play with people I
think so I I want to do a settings menu
so people can change their own intervals
here let me actually see yeah that'll
just count down real fast
oh yeah like a stopwatch timer that's
kind of it looks cool though
all right undo all right so if this dot
total oh yeah total seconds that's right
a lot
okay so total seconds is less than or
equal to zero
then I'll call this dot stop and return
out of the function and I think so I
think that should work and just to test
that out I will do
well I guess I'll do this so I'm going
to temporarily change this to being five
seconds start
sweet so it reset because because the
timer's not going anywhere it must have
called the stop function and that's why
reset isn't disabled anymore
cool so let me undo that and okay so
total seconds this actually should be
computed because right now I'm just
betting on this being 25 but if I do
make this is actually easier than I
thought
yeah so what if I make a settings menu
so that the user can update these these
settings
[Music]
let's see what would a settings menu
look like I don't have a router in my
app so I don't want to route them I
don't want to bother installing it so
let me do a dialog click me
right
form dialogue yeah so I could have some
basic form elements in the dialogue like
this yeah I think I'll borrow this
so let me and actually the dialogue is
definitely going in its own component
because that's gonna be too much so user
settings let me just do that user it's
just I don't really have users dialogue
settings dialogue dot view let me do a
template and then I'll copy some of this
let me open this again okay close yeah
close it okay so let me copy this
and for right now yeah I'll just I'll
just see so I don't want the row I just
want a dialogue and go ahead and close
the card close the dialogue and I need
to first v-model so persistent means I
can't just close it by clicking outside
which is good for a forum oh cool it
gives me an animation too
so I have to click the close button and
now I need I need um V model so I'll
have to pass that in via props so let me
do a script tag here and props let's see
what I guess I'll just have a dialogue
prop and this will be a boolean so I'll
do type boolean and required is true
okay
what else oh yeah let me import this
component so I can start playing with it
where [ __ ] oh yeah in script tags I'll
do import settings dialog from settings
dialog view and then here I'll have to
register the components so settings
dialog I know I didn't lock up this
dialog but cuz this is just the basics
cuz I thought maybe I wasn't even gonna
get to it because all of these have
taken a little bit longer than I thought
but I guess the timer isn't that hard to
do so let's see so user can choose timer
yes so this is where I thought I was
gonna do they can select and this isn't
even real clear how I wrote this user
can choose timer short break or long
break oh no I think I was talking about
the top the tabs here oh yeah here is
where I was talking about setting so
user can set the number of minutes for
each type of timer yeah and this will be
actually the last requirement besides
some optional things I had in case I
needed more stuff to do so they can set
the number of minutes for each timer so
I guess I'll just be like three input
boxes and then they can update the
minutes if they want so
what am i doing oh yeah I imported the
settings dialog so now I can put it in
here
so I'll put it do I really have two
cards yeah I do have two cards that's
fine so I'll put it here and I need to
pass it a dialog boolean so let me do
that
and then I need to create the dialogue
boolean here let me do it after timers I
guess so dialogue and I'll do false
oh I did it inside of timers so let me
yeah do it after timers wait okay dialog
is false I'm passing that in here oh
right so the thing that I'm doing here
I'm passing it in as a prop but I'm
still using this activator button so I
actually need to turn this off get rid
of that and just put some text here as a
placeholder okay and now I need some
kind of a Settings button on the page
and I think what I'm gonna do is a
floating acts
a floating action button since I'm using
material anyway so floating floating
action buttons
need some water
I feel like I've been talking forever
does anyone have any questions
suggestions anything anything else to
talk about okay let me do floating yeah
I think I can just steal one of these
these are just regular buttons where is
it oh it's a V button but it's just set
as fab it's given this fab prop okay so
I'm gonna copy this let's see let me put
it just on the page somewhere actually
it shouldn't even be inside a v card so
I wonder if I should put this in app let
me try it here V button oops
[Music]
okay
waste maestro oh it's that teacher it
confuse with maestro let's see okay
wait I have a dialogue and MDI plus so
let me do em di settings and just guess
that there's a Settings icon
or is it gear oh cool it might be gear
icon it's not gear either let me
actually look at ICON so material design
setting this page always takes me a
while to load for some reason yeah what
is what is this one
oh it's cog outline so MDI cog outline
let's see what this one is yeah this is
good except for the color color is not
nice but we do secondary for the color
yeah that's okay um let's see so this is
left let me do right
okay and that actually doesn't look bad
there it doesn't look great but it
doesn't look bad and it's away from
everything else so now if I click it I
need to what do I need to do open the
dialog yeah well I don't want small
though
let me oh no I do want small I do what
small all right maybe top right let me
try top right no then it's over the tab
I would actually like it on the page up
here but then I'm gonna have to do this
in the parent so I have to do in app so
here
did it change back to pink did I copy I
think I copied the wrong thing well I
don't know it just happened that's weird
oh well secondary talk right
oh wow that's off the page okay so that
should probably be inside of the
container then so let me put it here
yeah which is why that's the big reason
why I use vyas code vim instead of
regular vim now because of copy-pasting
oh yeah and this was cog cog outline so
why let me see let me try inside the row
then otherwise I'm gonna look in dev
tools and see why it's doing that
nope it doesn't doesn't like it okay
so it is absolute
let me try getting rid of absolute okay
so now that puts it here which isn't
actually bad up here and then I think if
I move to outside of the row it would go
more towards here but since everything
is so centered right now I think I'll
just leave it here but now I need to I
need to have data inside this component
so then I know this is not too important
but I just I like to have a return
statement keep everything the same so we
do return and I'll have what will I call
it here so I'll call it dialogue from
here so I'll have dialogue is false and
then
when they click on the button it sets
weight at click so at a click event
it sets dialogue to true ok and then I
need to pass in that dialogue to
Pomodoro so let me pass in dialogue as
dialog if I have UX I wouldn't need to
be passing to grandchildren but there's
so few components guess it's ok I'm just
passing one thing
okay so dialogue I passed it into
Pomodoro so now I need to receive it in
Pomodoro via props here so let me do
props wait
props object and I'm getting dialogue
which is the type is boolean required is
true all right and now I didn't put it
here oh yeah I did put it here so let me
take it off of there
okay so I have dialogue and passing in
dialogue here ok what else do I need to
do then I'll see it opens oh but it's
persistent and I have no close button
let me add the buttons then so let me go
back to dialogue in here the dialogue in
here and where was the forum one yeah
I'm just gonna keep copying from here so
[Music]
the card actions
oh right I will be able to set dialogue
to false from in the component I'm gonna
have to yeah I don't have I'm gonna have
to call an event or a method or
something or just install view x4 one
small thing where was I where was it
okay so in Pomodori oh now no no in
settings dialog inside of card I'm going
to add the actions and dialogue I can't
do dialogue is false so should I do a
custom event I haven't used events and
so long because I've pretty much just
used view X or pass things between
components should I do
yeah let me try doing a view custom
event view custom event
okay so the myth events that's basically
the same as doing listening to the kebab
case version right and I think in view
three actually this syntax got better
too so maybe I don't
yeah maybe I'll skip events and oh wait
it didn't throw an error
I changed props yeah
avoid mutating prop directly so that's
just a warning actually oh yeah but now
it doesn't open now because I changed
the prop from inside inside the child
component so let me let me just pass
down a method see how that works I think
that will be easier so methods let me do
close but not close modal because it's
called dialogue so close dialogue and
this dot dialogue equals false
and then I'll have to pass the method in
to pomodoro here so I have to pass in
close dialogue equals close dialogue and
then let's see close dialogue yep it's
spelled correctly so that's okay that's
an app now I need another prop so after
the close dialogue type is a function
acquired is true and now I need to pass
this in okay so accept it in props now I
need to pass it into settings dialogue
so
close dialogue equals close dialogue and
now at the event oh yeah I need to do
that
okay so now I have closed dialogue and
now let's see let me try to do it in the
cancel button and call clothes
dialogue at click so I don't like how
long this line is all right let me do
the same thing here so save okay oh it
doesn't like it invalid handler for
click got undefined okay so it didn't
like whatever I did
let's see make sure I'm clicking close
oh no wait it closed just fine okay I
just needed to refresh I guess so for
save I'm gonna have a different method
so here I'll do save yeah I'll just call
it safe because there's nothing else
going on
so after props I need to do methods here
and I'll do
I just tried to click your clothes
button Oh on the screen that would be
really cool if I could do interactive
live streams where people could type and
hit buttons I guess if I did glitch or
something I don't know how many people
could be in there though it might crash
that's I think that's the future of
live-streaming the next evolution will
be interactive streams
yeah the save method could and since the
data is in there I guess yeah that's a
good idea so let me just receive that
then so save would be of type function
and required is true
[Music]
that click yeah so that will call the
parent and now get out of there so now
in here I'll need to have a save method
that I pass in so let me put this on
some new lines okay settings okay so now
I need to make a save method and I
should trying to save yeah because
there's no other save functionality in
the app so I can just call it save so
let me do save and I will need to call
this dot close dialog though because I
do want it to close when I hit save so
let me try that out okay
save yeah it close this fine
all right yeah you're right it makes
more sense to put it in there so now I
need the form items in here and I also
want a header so let's see oh I have
four minutes wonder if I should one
second
yeah let me try to get as much done as I
can so the card title yeah I want the
title so let me put this in my studying
this dialogue and get rid of that here
I'll do I'll just put settings and then
here I'll do the card text and then in
here I'll put the forum items so what
should I put I guess just input and then
let me find oh wait wait that's not what
I want I want text fields
and then I think I can get a number here
or yeah I can put the typist whatever I
want
prefix and suffix yeah I can add
validation and we'll have time to do
validation for it unfortunately but let
me just get a basic text field bed and
you have V text field that's it and I'll
put it inside here oops so oh yeah
I'll make it self-closing and then label
will be Pomodoro and they'll make three
of these so was it short actually I can
loop over these so I need to pass in my
timers to this now so let me pass in
this whole timers object to settings so
I'll pass in timer's equals timers and
[Music]
let's see and now I can loop through
I'll let me receive it first so put it
before save so timer's type is OP nhoa
rae rae required equals is true
okay and yeah so the text fields yeah
this is what I want to loop through I
guess oh but then I have to save mm I'm
gonna have to save the unless I want to
directly v-model no I can't
I'm gonna have to set the default as the
timer amount and then save the new
amount that's entered and it is 12 right
now so I'm not sure okay I am just
messaging 3 code camp
all right and yeah it's getting more
complicated so what I can do is okay so
I can loop through and display here
that's easy enough
but I want to actually save a new time
so actually my V model here has to be
something new so this is gonna have to
be updated timers and I think that I can
set a default on data here so I could do
my default timers and this could be an
array of times and then I could say when
this component is mounted is this the
best way to do it I don't know I'm just
trying to get this done or thought
through I guess who we want more of it
is yeah I don't want to hold it up too
much longer but unmounted so unmounted I
could set these default timers to be
whatever I pass in as timers to start so
I could do let's see if I loop through
this top timers top map the result will
be default timers and dot map and then I
get the timer in here so that's an
object that's a timer object and then I
can return
whatever I return oh yeah timer dot was
a timer duck time Oh minutes minutes
okay I think that will work and now I
have a brand new array in here that I
can v-model to so I can loop through
here I can do B 4 equals did I really
call it default why is it called default
I should be calling this like updated
updated timers updated timers yeah this
isn't the perfect solution really but I
guess it can be refactored because then
if they don't update anything am I just
gonna save everything anyway oh I
already called it updated timers here
wait what is Oh it's complaining oh yeah
I don't have the find key yet so so let
me do updated timers and then set a key
here to be what do I want for the key
let me just do oh I didn't even let me
do time timer in our timer and then I in
updated timers and then the key can just
be I right here
okay and then the v-model will be
updated timers I so it will be that at
that index in the array where the timer
will model to that index basically okay
so data property must be a function did
I do that oh yeah let me change this oh
and then I have to return from here to
oh wait return an object and then let me
just do updated timers what why isn't my
shift button working oh there we go and
this is an empty array okay okay it
doesn't like what I'm doing oh yeah it
does sweet awesome so let me look at the
v-model then in the which component is
that in its oh yeah it's inside of
settings the settings dialog component
so I have okay so i have props which are
the timer objects the timers array of
objects and then I have in my component
that I have updated timers sweet cool
it does change it to a string as soon as
I change this but then I could just save
let me see if I can set up the save
function in just a few minutes so in
save I can pass the updated timers let's
say let's say I just passed the updated
timers that's like an easy way to save
this and then what am I doing here
where's the save function so save will
take updated timers and the easiest
easiest thing to do I mean this has no
validation or anything so just hope I'm
typing in actually I can do the easiest
form of HTML validation and say that the
type of this is a number so they can't
put in anything else oh yeah and then it
won't change to a string either let me
validate that real quick
but shouldn't change to a string does it
or does it just do that for every HTML
input okay let me open the settings
dialog again and now when I change a
timer yeah it still changes to a string
oh well that's fine
now I can do second loop through timers
second loop through this dot
hmm yeah I could look through this top
timers and then update values or what
should I do
I should loop through updated timers
right I know I could I should do this
timers equals this dot timers top map
and then do timer and then I could do
return updated timer you know what am i
doing I'm not even thinking right now um
I could do timer no I need to return an
object so I need to get everything
that's already on timer in the object
which would just be the name and then
I'll overwrite the minutes so the
minutes will be overwritten by updated
timers at the index of whatever this is
in the loop so at that index so I can do
that updated timers yeah because this is
an array updated timers is an array and
that will put just that one value in two
minutes and that will overwrite the
minutes that's already in the timer and
the stat timers okay let's see if this
works and actually this needs to be a
number
so let me parse it real quick so parse
int because I'm not dealing with seconds
so I'm just gonna
yeah I don't want anything else just
minutes so parse int it's default based
10 update timers okay let me close this
and refresh let's see oh oh yeah because
that is not wait let me see we change
this to to save yeah short break is to
now long break is 10 this is 20
oh because the default is that okay well
can I in data does anyone know if I can
reference this as the default like
timers this dot current timer well I'd
have to do this here too so would be
this dot this dot current timer and then
no I have to watch those them I guess
I'd have to watch it so I would have to
watch the changes in these and then
update total seconds and that's what I
should be doing to probably add that and
computed so whenever anything in timers
changes I can update the total seconds
but you can still I mean this still
works it's just you have to change the
tab before you can see it working and
then you can still start/stop reset all
right so I have to log off here feel
free to you know make a PR raise an
issue create a suggestion I appreciate
everyone who's made suggestions raised
this is ashik Paul I think that's how
you pronounce it he contributed a couple
times to the other projects I've been
doing made them a little bit better I
Thank You Aneesh I appreciate that and
thanks for chatting everybody I
appreciate the chat and not talking to
myself that's that always feels nice
so yeah here are the five projects some
of them better than others today's was
probably the best-looking project that
pretty much works but could use some
some TLC some help
in some ways yeah if you have any
suggestions for me also leave them in
the comments below and I hope to see you
in another livestream thanks Sachi
thanks everybody
take care